what's going on guys this is Rob and I
imagine a lot of you were just kind of
like wow what's going on here like what
is all this what's this whole thing on
the screen well first things first for
one this video is best watched in
full-screen mode but too because of the
direction that the YouTube comic-book
community is going in we kind of have
this mishmash of things going on across
different channels we have some channels
that are strictly face cams and they
talk about comics we have some channels
that are more directed towards comics
and have very little face can't mom be a
good example of that and so I figured
why not bridge the gap between these two
things and have a facecam alongside
comic book information in the same video
so I'm a little nervous about this
layout this is obviously a work in
progress this is obviously something
that will change over time that
hopefully will evolve but any
constructive criticism that you guys
have feel free to leave it down in the
comment section and I'll definitely you
know look over them and try to make
changes accordingly but what you guys
will see on this page as you will see of
course on the the far side with regards
to the section under more videos you'll
see links to various videos that I have
what you will also see is that
occasionally I will reference a video
and what I do you'll see a pop out just
like this one that will tell you what is
going on it'll tell you whether or not
you can click on that and I basically
take you to the video then I'm
referencing what you'll also find down
at the very bottom of the page are links
to my Twitter to monstercat media which
is what I use for the music at the end
of the videos and you'll also see a link
to my patreon if you guys are interested
in contributing to that and of course
the subscribe button that most everybody
has so anyway what we're going to do in
this video is we're going to talk about
the time runs out secret Wars
lead up basically this video is going to
be designed to inform you what you need
to be reading if what you're wanting to
do is to get yourself prepared for
Secret Wars 2015 so what I've done here
is I've made a few notes and for the
most part we can basically kick things
off with Marvel now with Jonathan
Hickman's run of The Avengers and New
Avengers now Jonathan Hickman took over
Avengers and New Avengers basically to
lay out the lay the groundwork for
Secret Wars to basically set things on
the past so that Marvel could implement
this grandiose plan to reboot their
multi
the hickman run of Avengers is
colloquially I guess referred to as
Avengers vol 5 that's basically what
that is New Avengers is New Avengers vol
3 now the way the stories initially
unfold the brunt of things the meat and
potatoes with regards to the incursions
is covered under New Avengers now for
those of you guys who haven't seen my
video on the incursions which you can
click that link to see it New Avengers
incursions were basically the way in
which Marvel was rebooting their
multiverse what had happened here was
that black panther in Wakanda was the
first one to encounter an incursion and
an incursion is a circumstance whereby
an earth from an alternate reality will
basically appear in the sky of another
earth in which is about to crash into
over the course of eight hours they'll
move closer and closer and then when
that 8 hour deadline passes the earth
will crash into one another if both
earths collide both the realities are
destroyed if one of the Earth's is
destroyed then both realities survive
except the one reality is just simply
one earth less it doesn't have an earth
on it and so what we find here is that
as a result of this incursion and of
course there's other things that go into
it again this is just kind of a run over
here we see the black panther brings the
Illuminati back together again and so
what happens over the course of these
initial issues leading up to issue
number 17 or 18 I think of New Avengers
is that for the most part the Illuminati
are just trying to find a way to end the
incursions peacefully and what's really
cool here about this is this is when we
see a lot of the incursion is taking
place this is when we see a lot of the
alternate realities a lot of the
different versions of the Illuminati we
see for example versions of the
Illuminati that are composed of
different members than the one on
earth-616 some of which have dr. doom is
part of the Illuminati some of which
have magneto in Charles Xavier one of
which is actually I guess numbered earth
for million and something rather I can't
really exact numerical designation but
this is effectively a universe whereby
all the Marvel heroes were basically
killed off and in their place came the
Great Society which is basically the DC
Universe inside the Marvel Universe is
pretty much what this is but again this
is to set the groundwork this is to get
us familiarized with what's going on in
the Marvel Universe that's
more along the line in the multiverse
that an earth had been destroyed and
because that earth had been destroyed
there had basically been an aftershock
there had been a chain reaction and it's
reality was destroyed and so because of
this it left a void and the multiversal
space and the multiversal landscape and
so what literally started happening is
different earths started bumping into
each other and again their reality
started being destroyed and so what we
find is the Illuminati begin to kind of
panic here they begin to try to freak
out and try to find a way to end the
incursions so one of the ways in which
they choose with Captain America
wielding it is the Infinity Gauntlet now
the Infinity Gauntlet is initially
successful at ending one incursion but
the result is that all of the infinity
gems with the exception of the time Jim
shatter the time Jim itself actually
disappears it's presumably lost in time
and so what happens as the Illuminati
begin experimenting with more I guess
nefarious actions they basically begin
contemplating the idea of using violence
of wiping out other Earth's now Captain
America is initially against this he's
avidly against the idea of killing
people as far as he's concerned there
has to be a better way to end the
incursions than the loss of life and so
what happens is that because Captain
America is effectively outvoted by
pretty much everybody Captain America's
mind is white of the entire incursions
event and he's basically sent back to
his normal life and I'm sorry dr.
Stephen strange is the one that actually
ends up doing this now all this really
comes to a head with the original sin
event and this is basically the reason
why original sin happened this was
pretty much Marvel giving us the reason
original sin also gave us silk which I
would go as far as to say may have been
one of the big reasons why we got
original sin but there were other ways
to write silk in original sin really
seem to basically revolve around the
idea of Captain America and setting the
stage for the Avengers what happens here
is that as we know with our original sin
series which again you can click the
link down there and you're welcome to go
and check it out is a Captain America
had been exposed to the eye of The
Watcher alongside a multitude of other
superheroes and as a result he was
basically blasted with everything that
The Watcher had seen and referenced to
him which included Doctor Strange wiping
his memory of the incursions and so he
basically recalled everything and so
what happens here
is we begin to pick up with the whole
idea of Avengers now Avengers had been
going on vengers vol 5 the early stories
were Avengers world but this is really
worthy Avengers and the New Avengers
start to cross paths and start to bump
heads Captain America's attitude here is
that if the Illuminati are effectively
going through and they're wiping out
worlds if they're going through and
they're killing people for the purpose
of trying to end the incursions then
he's basically branded them as traitors
he's basically said that because of the
actions are committing that they're no
longer I guess a superhero group they're
basically a rogue group of vigilantes
and so what this does is a sort of
brings an end to the early stories to
the incursion event so to speak with
regards to Marvel Comics and it kicks
off time runs out and this is what
you're hearing whenever Marvel says and
eight months time runs out and two
months time runs out this basically
begins to chronicle what happens after
the events of Captain America labeling
the the New Avengers the Illuminati as
traitors and then pursuing them
accordingly this is when we see the
design and I guess the implementation of
the multiversal Avengers where the
Avengers basically begin traversing the
multiverse to try to find a way to end
the incursions this is when we start
getting into the ivory priests a little
more I'm sorry the black priests a
little more when we begin to get a
little more into the ivory kings and
different things like that and of course
we'll get far more in depth into this
once we get closer to to the Secret Wars
event and we begin to see the conclusion
of time runs out but this is basically a
circumstance whereby everything is
leading up to the Secret Wars thing now
for the most part there came a point
during the time runs out event where
there was basically a very large low
period there was a point at which not a
whole lot happen that seemed very
interesting it was important but the
problem was that there wasn't a whole
lot of action there was a lot of
dialogue and a lot of discussion this
was largely the events that took place
after infinity one of the big things and
of course if you want to see the video
about infinity you're welcome to click
the link which will take you over to
binney's channel he's actually got the
complete story for infinity but one of
the things that had happened here one of
the things that Jonathan Hickman had
done with the Avengers is he had
basically continued them along the path
of engaging in their own actions of
doing their own thing of fighting their
own villains and so on and so forth but
in the background the incursions were
always going on the incursions were
continuing on
so during the infinity event while we
saw Captain America and his team dealing
with the builders dealing with Thanos
and the Inhumans and all that kind of
good stuff
the Illuminati were still dealing with
the incursions they were still focusing
on the incursions and trying to find a
way to bring the incursions to an end
and again this really all kind of tied
in to the incursions event and time went
out and all that kind of good stuff and
so what is up happening here is that
eventually we get to a point where name
of the Submariner after having a
destroyed a world basically creates his
own cabal his own group of people which
consists of Proxima midnight Thanos
Corvus glaive and so on and so forth
whereby he goes about the process of
raising other worlds his assumption here
his idea is that if the Illuminati had
cast him out for destroying a planet
because they had considered other
options than who's going to destroy the
planets on his own because as far as he
was concerned he was really the only
member of the Illuminati that had the
gumption to do what was necessary to
pervert to preserve the multiverse now
in the current events and what's
currently going on right now with the
whole Avengers and New Avengers thing is
that the entire superhero community the
Avengers the New Avengers everybody has
pretty much come together for the
realization that there's no way to stop
what's happening Hank Pym had traveled
from the I guess from the multiverse
back to the current location of the the
Illuminati and this is when we learned
that Hank Pym was an Illuminati that
when the incursions initially started
happening that somewhere along the line
Reed Richards had sent Hank Pym into the
multiverse to find a way to either find
the source of the incursions or to end
the incursions and what Hank Pym had
found here was that the beyonders were
basically going through and wiping out
all the cosmic entities and all these
different alternate realities and that
ultimately they had destroyed the Living
Tribunal and when the Living Tribunal
was destroyed a different version or I
guess a version of a Living Tribunal
landed on the moon and every single
reality that existed in an infinite
number of realities and so as it stands
right now for pretty much all the cosmic
entities are gone all the Celestials are
gone the only I guess cosmic entity that
exists out there right now is the one
above all and we have no earthly clue
what's going on there we haven't haven't
heard word one about
one above all we have no clue what's
taking place what was also taught to us
and again I have a link to the beyonders
and our video down below is that the
beyonders have either initiated this set
of incursions have initiated the entire
incursion event or they were there when
it began happening and are really
looking at it as more of an experiment
we're not a hundred percent sure about
this and the reason why is because the
other half of this equation is Doctor
Doom what had happened here was that
there was an incursion that had taken
place on the planet Earth whereby I
guess the mapmakers which again is part
of our incursion discussion we're not
going to go too far into them but they
had arrived at the planet Earth but
suffice it to say without getting into
deep dr. doom had basically taken a
piece of this alternate earth which was
destroyed and began to analyze it and as
a result he had effectively mapped the
multiverse and so what he intended to do
was travel back to the source point back
to the origination of the incursions and
find out how it all started and
presumably maybe stop it from actually
happening in the first place but
ultimately ultimately what happens here
is that he's taken by molecule man by
Owen Reese to the space beyond the
Marvel multiverse think of it as though
the Marvel multiverse exists inside of a
cup and that he had been taken beyond
this cup he had been taken outside of
this cup to the space outside of it and
it seems as far as what Jonathan Hickman
is telling us that perhaps Doctor Doom
was the cause of the incursions in the
first place and he basically created a
paradox again there's a lot of questions
that are kind of unanswered here but
these are the questions that will be
answered once we get closer to to the
start of suger wars this is one of the
reasons why I haven't done a video on
time runs out yet because I really
didn't want to present a video to you
guys and say there's just a lot of
things we don't know and kind of leave a
leave them up in the air and go from
there now again all this stuff is
covered up to the current run of
Avengers and new Avengers and what I'll
have down in the comments section is a
list of the trade paperbacks as well as
the individual issues so you can
actually go through in a reading order
and read the events as they happen
accordingly in addition to Hickman's run
of Avengers and new avengers there's
also a couple stories that I would
suggest a couple characters that I would
suggest you check out and the reason why
is because these are characters that are
going to going to continue on into
secret Wars but they're also very
important in terms of where they stand
and they're
their new creation the reason for this
is because with Thor core for example we
know there's going to be a virtual I
guess a mishmash of all these different
Thor's from all across the Marvel
landscape from all across the multiverse
as far as we've been told every single
Thor this ever existed that we've ever
seen some of whom we actually haven't
seen are going to be part of this Thor
core and so I would highly suggest that
you check out the current all-new
version of Thor if you haven't already
and again I have a video about that
version of Thor that you're welcome to
look at if you'd like to in addition to
this I would also highly suggest you
check out all new Captain America and
the reason why is because while this
isn't necessarily the highest selling
book the model has going on it's kind of
important because will most likely see
Sam Wilson continuing the role of
Captain America going into Secret Wars
and so once the course starts if we
begin referencing Sam Wilson and you
don't know his backstory it'll become
very confusing but again we'll do a
character discussion about him as well
so we'll we'll try to make sure that
everything makes sense once secret war
starts but there's also a few other
things Miles Morales and someone is so
forth but like I said well I'll try to
do a video on each one of these things
so that you can go into Secret Wars
fully prepared on the off chance that
getting Captain America comics just
isn't for you but that being said this
was fun this is actually a pretty cool
thing I really hope you guys enjoyed it
let me know again how you guys feel any
constructive criticism you guys have is
something that I'll take two take two to
mind and and analyze it and see what
kind of changes I can make to make this
whole thing better but without being
said and we'll catch you guys later
Silas come with my thoughts no one to
farm